the world will end next week then your
children's college fund
saw that turkey now who needs psychics
when we have the simpsons
the simpsons episodes have been
predicting major headline-worthy moments
for over 30 years
like donald trump becoming president so
we're taking a dive into all their
accurate predictions and just what 2021
could have in store for us
according to the simpsons it's pretty
safe to assume that during donald
trump's apprentice years
nobody guessed he'd be taking office
except for the simpsons
in a season 11 episode called bart to
the future bart travels to the future
where lisa wins the oval
office after donald trump allegedly
ruined the economy
we're broke the prediction of him being
president was so specific
we'll probably never get over it check
out this side-by-side comparison
as you know we've inherited quite a
budget crunch from president trump
while we were all busy thinking the
world was going to end back in 2012
the simpsons writers were busy
predicting what the 2017 super bowl
halftime show would look like
telesin song the episode called lisa
goes gaga had a special guest
surprise it's me gaga during the episode
she puts on an epic performance that has
her suspended in the air from cables
cut to the 2017 halftime show and the
real gaga did
exactly that not to mention at one point
their outfits are eerily similar
whether you're a fan of original disney
movies or not the production company has
probably managed to creep into your
everyday life
somehow so was it really that shocking
when disney announced their fox takeover
not really but you know who was probably
less surprised
the simpsons writers this prediction
happened all the way back in 1998 where
they showed 21st century fox as a
division of walt disney co
the motto of 2020 was truly we're all in
this together
but the simpsons did unintentionally
warn its audience that a pandemic like
the coronavirus was completely possible
in the 90s episode margin charge the
dreaded osaka flu
has hit springfield with over 300 cases
now reported
a dangerous virus arrives in springfield
from japan
and fans couldn't help but notice the
similarities between the fictional osaka
flu
and covet 19. some people have debunked
the claims that this was a coronavirus
prediction
but they got the global pandemic part of
it spot on
happy birthday happy birthday
what else did 2020 hit us with this year
right
murder hornets ironically the simpsons
called these
deadly insects in the same episode some
think they predicted the coronavirus
in one specific scene citizens are
calling on their leader for a vaccine
for the virus
while protesting they managed to knock
open a truck full of the murder hornets
coincidence
oh no if you were a toys r us kid not
anymore
you had to say farewell to a big chunk
of your childhood back in 2018.
as soon as the closure was announced
fans rushed to social media with
theories that a 2004 simpsons episode
forewarned of the company's bankruptcy
in the episode childless adults decide
their next move is to destroy
everything that children enjoy because
that's logical of course
anyway in one clip a man flips the r in
the store logo backward while a group of
children watch in tears
okay so yeah it's a little bit of a
stretch when it comes to accuracy but
people are totally convinced that this
was a prediction that came true
we never would have had these kids if we
thought we had to pay for them
at one point everyone was concerned
about what daenerys and her dragons
would get up to in the newest episode of
game of thrones
but the simpsons were like we know
exactly what's gonna go down
look the dragon is burning our village
in 2007 they aired an episode that
people believed predicted daenerys
burning king's landing in the show's
final season
there's nothing like a good old
love-hate relationship with autocorrect
that's a conflicted look am i right our
phone's just
really really want us to always say duck
surprise the simpsons had a 90s episode
that featured predictive texting
and get this the episode aired in 1994
more than a decade before the first
prototypes of autocorrect were ever made
guitar hero probably brings back
nostalgic saturday nights jamming to
songs like hit me with your best shot
did you guys ever make it to the expert
level the 2005 video game name
was first seen in a 2002 episode of the
simpsons
the season 14 episode had mick jagger
and keith richards giving homer a jacket
that read guitar hero
and then bam three years later guitar
hero was born
right i get it who else has had an apple
watch on their holiday wish list
well you're definitely not alone one in
five people in america actually have a
smart watch
and the simpsons knew way back in 1995
that they would become a thing
in an episode that flashes into the
future lisa's husband is seen talking
into his watch that looks scarily
similar to an apple watch
you might not know him but bengt r
holstrom is an economics genius
he even won a nobel prize for his work
back in 2016.
now the simpsons might not have a nobel
prize but they do have plenty of emmys
and a handful of future predictions
including holstrom's win
check out this clip that proclaims
holstrom's future way to go milhouse
siegfried and roy were pretty iconic
magicians back in the early 2000s
but tragically struck during one of
their las vegas shows
they had an incident with their white
tiger monticor that caused their entire
show to shut down
well ten years prior the simpsons had
sick freedom void look-alikes in one of
their episodes
their performance in the episode also
ended in a tiger attack
now let's take a look at what the
simpsons believe 2021
and beyond have in store for us but this
will be so confusing
the simpsons aren't sparing anyone's
feelings when it comes to what they
think the presidential inauguration day
has in store for us
in one of their newer episodes on
january 20 2021 they show the world
overtaken by robots while everything
burns in the background
this admittedly sounds like a far cry
from what january will probably be like
but who really knows what's to come at
this point right
ooh that's me in the future wait you're
about to see something
so this next one is completely possible
and is already happening
what are you guys doing here if someone
told us that we'd one day live on mars
20 years ago we'd probably laugh but
we've come a long way
in the simpsons world they predicted
that we'd be exploring mars by the year
2026
believe it or not they might be spot on
nasa and even elon musk are planning a
mars mission in this decade
yes that's why i want to do it you
heard of virtual reality but have you
ever heard of virtual reality food
is it just us or does that sound like a
catchphrase for some kind of futuristic
unhealthy weight loss program it wasn't
that to homer and marge simpson however
in an episode where the simpsons
experience the future we're introduced
to a device that lets them eat without
actually eating
it might sound strange but it does seem
like something that could one day happen
especially with how fast vr is moving
okay so the simpsons can't take all the
credit for this next one
hologram mail some form of holographic
messaging has popped up in
a lot of futuristic movies and tv series
but again this is totally something that
could be coming in the next few years i
mean remember when they literally
brought michael jackson back as a
hologram
hologram for bart simpson
global warming has become a pretty big
topic around the world which means of
course the simpsons would take it on
in the simpsons movie springfield gets
its own glass dome in order to stop the
town's air pollution from getting out
uh that's one way to contain something
while something of this nature could
definitely be in our future
we're just gonna stick with recycling
for now can you swing
from a web no we can't he's a pig
are analog clocks a thing of the past
well the simpsons sure think so
so much so that they made some
adjustments to the big ben in london for
their futuristic episodes
they think the famous clock will be
getting a digital makeover in the years
to come
this may be the most realistic
prediction yet
i only want to eat candy a baby
translator 100
would have been useful for the 80s film
look who's talking but it's been over 30
years and we still don't have one
in one episode of the simpsons the
simpsons get their hands on a baby
translator for maggie
well here it is again my baby translator
honestly it's a wild idea but we're not
doubting any of the show's predictions
at this point
donald trump wasn't the simpsons only
presidential prediction
they also foresee trump's daughter
ivanka trump running for president in
2028.
you can see homer showing his support
for her by wearing this pin
check it out don't get any ideas
okay so we aren't ready to base our
lives around various simpsons episodes
but you have to admit what they've
accurately predicted so far is pretty
wild how do you feel about the simpsons
thoughts on 2021
drop your thoughts in the comments below
we can't wait to read through it all
thanks for watching